what do you think of the World Cup
situation it's been very funny to watch
the Western World try and complain at
Qatar like we have some degree of moral
High Ground because qataris don't want
to pollute their culture by promoting
LGBT garbage to kids we in the west
think that we are the only moral people
on Earth and if another culture says
that you shouldn't be promoting LGBT
ideals to children on television and
that football has nothing to do with gay
sex so just let it be football that
we're gonna somehow Pretend We're
morally obliged to attack their
institutions and their religious beliefs
the things we do in the west are
disgusting some under the guise of lbgt
whether it's chopping kids dicks off or
just some other things in general are
discussing like all the wars we start
and the innocent people we kill to sit
here and pretend that we as a western
conglomerate are the only moral people
on earth is truly asinine and I respect
the qataris for standing up what they
believe in and I don't see why religious
beliefs should be thrown out the window
temporarily for sports anyways